I don't know if you guys have been
paying attention the entertainment
business but a bad time to be a predator
if you're doing that cut it out it sucks
we're losing like three actors a day I
feel like I'm gonna see the New Avengers
movie like why is everyone being played
by Paul Giamatti they're like he's the
only one left
so weird time there's a hockey team
called the Predators the Nashville
Predators which in this climate very
ballsy because it's actors now but it's
gonna be athletes next and that's gonna
be a weird press release when they're
like we at the Predators are shocked
this is not what the predator stands for
we'd like to be known as the alleged
Predators as possible it's everywhere I
was in my hotel room earlier I was
watching a Law & Order SVU
the moms pushing the baby in the
stroller she turns around for like five
seconds she turns back around the baby's
gone which that's not even bad parenting
that's just pretty impressive kidnapping
you got to give credit where credit's
due because she's crying like I'm a
horrible mother and it's like nah he
just ran into one of the Great's you
know
it seems like there's a lot of bad stuff
happening and it seems like men are at
fault for a lot of it mass shootings
always a man right women they'll murder
their boyfriend their husband but
they're not killing strangers I think
men and women for the most part they
killed the way they make love
men are like I will kill anything
women are like I got to get to know you
first you want to get murdered by me you
might have to work for it a little
things are getting worse I'm getting
worse back in the day all I needed was a
picture of jennifer Love Hewitt's smile
fully aroused now it's harder these days
I'm having sex with an actual woman
she's choking me I'm like tell me I'm
adopted she's like one
that's what it takes now I'm not happy
about it it's a dark time freshly out of
a relationship I'm wearing condoms again
it's very upsetting it's not that bad
guys complain about wearing a condom you
know what it's like this is what it's
like to do to wear a condom you ever go
to a basketball court and there's no net
and you're like I mean I guess I'll play
the whole time you're like did that even
go in I was with a girl who asked me not
to wear condom she was like I'd rather
you didn't wear one I was like wearing
one she's like I'd rather you didn't I
was like I've made my decision
I'm gonna wear one she's like I just
prefer you then I was like I can't
believe we're having this argument also
I can't believe which side of it I'm on
I'm gonna wear one she goes why I was
like why because based on this I don't
think you're gonna be a good mother
that's why I'm a good boyfriend we're on
and off we'll figure it out but uh we
were together for two and a half years I
never cheated and a lot of people like
what's your secret to staying faithful
on the road two and a half years I never
cheated once oh I know my secret this is
my secret not one woman tried to have
sex with me
[Applause]
that's how I did it am I here oh yeah
some would say so be alone and playing
beautiful women walking towards and I'd
be like this check better not sit next
to me she'd sit next to me we won't
speed the entire flight it'd be like
that was a close call
I'm an amazing person one thing I miss
about having sex for my axes that she
would always give me credit for the
orgasm it's very nice
I'm not doing mush you know I mean I
could be having sex and she'd be like
you know I'm about to you know and I'd
be like all right cool then she'd be
like stay completely still and I'd be
like all right and then she'd be like
you just gave me that right that was me
it feels like I played that with an
erection but do you say so
that's all I went to the barbershop and
I can you hold the buzzer completely
still
you're the best I've ever had thank you
so much
[Applause]
you